Si cela fait longtemps que vous n'avez pas assisté à un cours d'histoire,
voici ce que dit vraiment le deuxième amendement :
« Une milice bien organisée
étant nécessaire à la sécurité d'un État libre,
le droit qu'a le peuple de détenir et de porter des armes
ne sera pas transgressé. »
Le gouvernement fédéral ne peut pas transgresser le droit des citoyens
de participer à des milices bien organisées.
Le deuxième amendement a été ratifié il y a 226 ans.
Il a été écrit avant que les forces armées du gouvernement fédéral
ne soient parmi les plus puissantes du monde
et quand les milices d’État étaient considérées nécessaires
à la protection des États.
Bond en avant de 80 ans, jusqu'en 1871.
La guerre de Sécession avait pris fin quelques années auparavant
mais quelques officiers de l'Union
avait été témoins d'une piètre adresse au tir sur le champ de bataille.
Afin de préparer leurs hommes pour les futurs conflits,
ils ont fondé la National Rifle Association
pour promouvoir les exercices de tir.
En bref, le deuxième amendement a été écrit pour assurer
que notre pays, nouvellement formé et fragile,
ait accès aux milices d’État organisées.
La mission initiale de la NRA était de s'assurer
que les futurs soldats sachent bien viser.
Quelqu'un pourrait donner un cours entier
sur comment les 150 années suivantes ont influencé les conversations
sur la réglementation des armes
que nous avons aux États-Unis
et notre interprétation du deuxième amendement.
Presque tous les moments décisifs de l'histoire de notre nation
ont influencé d'une certaine manière comment nous, en tant que peuple,
produisons, débattons, réglementons et voyons les armes à feu.
Beaucoup de changement ont eu lieu.
En effet, ce n'est qu'en 2008
que la Cour suprême a déclaré pour la première fois
que le deuxième amendement
protège un droit individuel de posséder une arme à feu
sans que cela ne soit lié à un service dans une milice
et l'utilisation de cette arme à des fins traditionnellement légitimes,
telles que l'autodéfense chez soi.
Chez soi.
L'évolution au fil du temps me semble frappante
car elle nous rappelle
que l'interprétation du deuxième amendement
et les attitudes culturelles en matière d'armes à feu
ont changé au fil du temps.
Ce qui me donne espoir de les voir changer à nouveau.
(Applaudissements)
C'est une leçon d'histoire incroyablement complexe et dynamique
mais ce n'est pas la leçon que je veux partager
car nous n'avons pas le temps.
Je ne parle pas de temps,
du temps que j'ai pour me tenir ici et parler.
Je parle du fait que nous n'avons pas de temps à perdre.
D'après une agence fédérale,
les cinq dernières années,
chaque jour, en moyenne, 96 personnes sont tuées par balle aux États-Unis
et si nous ne trouvons pas vite
comment répondre à la question de mes élèves,
l'un d'entre nous pourrait être le suivant.
Si la question est : comment mettre un terme à cette violence insensée,
la meilleure façon que je vois pour y répondre
est de considérer un choix multiple.
Vous vous souvenez des questions à choix multiple au lycée, n'est-ce pas ?
Commençons.
Choix A : Cela prendra fin
quand nous tiendrons les fabricants d'armes responsables
de la dangerosité de leurs produits.
Cela vous surprendra peut-être de savoir que nous avons pensé à cela auparavant.
Entre 1998 et 2000,
30 comtés et villes ont poursuivi des fabricants d'armes en justice,
en disant qu'ils devraient rendre leurs produits plus sûrs
et mieux garder la trace d'où leurs produits sont vendus.
En réponse, les fabricants ont avancé
qu'ils n'avaient aucune responsabilité directe
quant à l'utilisation de leurs produits.
Ils ont dit que les magasins vendant les armes
et les détenteurs les ayant achetées
étaient responsables, si un incident se produisait.
En réponse à cela et à beaucoup d'autres procès,
la NRA a poussé à l'adoption de l'APCLA,
l'Acte de protection du commerce légitime d'armes.
L'APCLA a été adopté en 2005 avec l'appui des deux partis
et confie aux fabricants d'armes le soin
de concevoir des armes de façon sûre,
aux magasins de vendre ces armes de façon sûre
et aux individus de détenir et utiliser une arme de façon responsable.
Alors que 17 élèves et membres du personnel sont morts dans mon école,
personne dans cette chaîne n'en assumera la responsabilité.
Considérons une autre option.
Choix B :
Cela prendra fin quand nous nous tiendrons pour responsables
et réglementerons les 300 millions d'armes que l'on estime disponibles en Amérique.
Oui, voter est l'une des meilleures façons
d'assumer personnellement sa responsabilité dans la violence armée.
S'assurer que nos législateurs soient prêts à passer des réformes de bon sens
concernant les armes
est l'une des façons les plus efficaces
de reprendre le contrôle sur ces 300 millions d'armes.
Les détenteurs d'armes peuvent également prendre une initiative personnelle.
Si vous détenez une arme,
demandez-vous :
« Ai-je une arme dont je n'ai pas besoin ?
Pourrait-elle tomber entre de mauvaises mains ?
Ai-je assisté au dernier entraînement ? »
En tant que détenteur d'arme,
vous devriez vous demander
si vous avez pris soin de votre santé mentale.
Quand il s'agit de violence armée,
l'argument sur la santé mentale tombe à plat
si nous ne reconnaissons pas nos vulnérabilités personnelles
aux maladies mentales.
Un Américain sur six luttera contre une maladie mentale.
Si nous possédons une arme, nous devrions être rigoureusement engagés à maintenir
notre bien-être mental
afin de ne pas appuyer sur la gâchette
en temps de maladie.
Autrement, nous devrions sérieusement nous demander
si nous avons le temps et l'attention nécessaires à la détention d'une arme.
Peut-être que pour certains d'entre nous,
il est temps de déposer nos armes.
Puis nous avons le choix C :
Cela prendra fin quand nous prendrons meilleur soin les uns des autres.
Les problèmes sociaux influencent pourquoi les gens achètent et utilisent des armes.
Aux États-Unis, 67% des morts par balle
entre 2012 et 2016 étaient des suicides.
Pourtant nous traitons les gens de « fous » et « cinglés », les humilions.
Nous créons des obstacles pour les gens ayant besoin d'aide.
Pourquoi nous humilions-nous les uns les autres ?
Facilitons, ne compliquons pas
l'accès des gens à de meilleurs soins de santé mentale.
Quoi d'autre ?
Le sexisme, le racisme et la pauvreté influencent la possession d'armes
et les morts liées à une arme à feu.
En moyenne, on estime que 50 femmes ont été tuées par balle chaque mois
entre 2010 et 2014
des suites de violences domestiques
et les femmes meurent encore chez elles.
Autonomisons les femmes
et donnons à nos garçons une chance d'apprendre
comment gérer leurs conflits et émotions avec des mots, pas avec des armes.
Le Washington Post a rapporté l'année dernière
près de 1 000 personnes mortellement blessées
par des officiers de police durant l'exercice de leurs fonctions.
Parlez à Black Lives Matter et au syndicat de police à ce sujet.
Nous devons nous régler cela.
(Applaudissements)
En fin de compte,
peut-être que les gens n'éprouveront pas le besoin
d'acheter et d'utiliser une arme
quand ils se sentiront tous autant en sécurité,
en bonne santé, respectés et aimés.
Il n'est plus l'heure de discuter.
Il est l'heure de répondre à la question.
Comment mettre un terme à cette violence insensée ?
Est-ce A,
B,
ou C ?
Je sais ce que vous pensez tous.
Les questions à choix multiples
ne finissent presque jamais avec trois possibilités.
Il y a toujours cette quatrième, choix D : Tout ce qui précède.
Peut-être que c'est la réponse.
Ou peut-être que « Tout ce qui précède » est trop facile
et ce n'est pas un problème facile.
Il requiert une réflexion analytique en profondeur de notre part à tous.
Je vous demande plutôt de faire vos devoirs,
d'écrire votre propre choix D
avec une justification détaillée.
Si vous ignorez où commencer, prenez mes élèves pour exemple.
Ils sont armés d'incroyables compétences en communication
et d'un sens de citoyenneté que je trouve si inspirant.
(Applaudissements)
Ce sont des élèves d'une école publique
s'occupant du problème de la réglementation des armes
et leur effort nous a émus.
Ils ne devraient pas avoir à faire cela seuls.
Ils vous demandent,
ils nous demandent à tous
de nous impliquer.
Il ne s'agit pas d'être spectateur.
Quelle est la bonne réponse ?
Je ne sais pas. Je ne suis pas experte en réglementation des armes.
J'enseigne les sciences humaines.
Être humain, c'est apprendre
et faire partie d'une civilisation, c'est partager vos connaissances.
Ce genre d'engagement honnête, courageux et sincère
est ce que je demande à mes élèves,
ce que j'attends de moi, en tant que professeur,
et ce que j'exige maintenant de vous.
Chacun d'entre vous doit faire ses devoirs.
Et après ?
Partagez humblement vos connaissances avec les autres.
S'il vous plaît, instruisez votre famille,
instruisez votre communauté,
votre conseil municipal, votre assemblée législative.
Donnez une leçon au Congrès.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)
Merci. Merci.